the vast oceans of the video game
subnautica and its sequel below zero
team with incredible life
some friendly and some deadly
while the series is focused on survival
the life forms of subnautica are amazing
even when they're trying to eat you
possessing fascinating biology bizarre
behavioral patterns and hidden mysteries
i've explored the various creatures of
the series before on my channel and in
this special compilation episode you can
get the full documentary style
experience in one video
from the sunlit shallows to the deepest
abyss we'll explore the biology behind
these puzzling aliens and discover the
role they play in their larger
ecosystems so let's take the plunge
together and see what awaits us under
the surface
beginning in the safety of shallow warm
waters we find that stable conditions
have led to a region crowded with varied
life
one of the first life forms we can spot
are the peepers or rather they spot us
with their enormous dinner plate like
eyes
these easily identifiable creatures have
evolved visual sensors capable of
discerning colors not just in clear
waters but in a variety of lighting
conditions
this combined with their surprising
speed means that despite being
herbivores peepers aren't at the bottom
of the food chain
that distinction instead belongs to
these creatures the rather unfortunate
looking garry fish docile herbivores
that are remarkably slow the garry fish
make easy prey for most anything else in
these shallow waters
all ecosystems including the oceans of
earth need something at the bottom of
the food chain after all
other common herbivores on 4546b include
the bladder fish which swims by
contracting and expanding its
translucent bladder in the unusual
boomerang a horizontally symmetrical
oddity that possesses a mouthful of
sharp teeth to break down coral
on the subject of coral the landscape of
the safe shallows is dominated by one
particularly unusual life form these
gargantuan tubes are large enough to
swim through and despite appearances are
very much alive
aptly named giant coral tubes they don't
look much like the coral we know on
earth
these tubes have evolved to filter
nutrients that flow through their center
and judging by their size and abundance
it's a strategy that has been quite
successful
gliding near the tubes is the elegant
rabbit ray the first of many race
species we may encounter the undulating
motion that the rabbit ray uses to swim
through the clear seas is analogous to
the underwater movements of various
types of earth rays
but it's not the movement of the rabbit
ray that gives it its curious name
instead the rabbit ray's most defining
features are its twin orange appendages
that help it sense vibrations
these ear-like structures resemble the
ears of rabbits and so the aquatic
rabbit ray shares a name with an
otherwise dissimilar terrestrial
herbivore
beneath the shallows twisted network of
underwater caves
while exploring one as i was gathering
this footage i heard a strange noise
and then a fish exploded in my face
that short-lived creature was a crash
fish an evolutionary oddity that is
difficult to study due to its highly
frustrating habit of exploding when
anything gets close
while an animal exploding to defend its
territory might seem too outlandish to
evolve there's a model of such behavior
on our own planet though in common
certain species of ants have been
observed erupting into goo to block
tunnels when their nest is under threat
truly nature is highly unusual no matter
the planet
elsewhere in the caves the far less
bothersome shuttle bugs drift near the
stone walls shuttle bugs are challenging
creatures to make sense of with three
legs and three mandibles that have
evolved into thin like tentacles
despite looking slightly unsettling
analysis suggests shuttle bugs are too
small to be a threat to most organisms
and have instead adapted to feed on the
waste products of the ecosystem around
them
leaving the caves you'll see our first
large species is waiting for us the
gasopods
these rotund leathery beasts resemble
earth manatees yet have a curious
defense that is all their own
although in no way hostile when
threatened gasopods will nonetheless
release a deadly cloud of underwater
mist which i can't recommend ingesting
chemical analysis of gasopods tells us
the poisonous compound comes from the
bulbous appendage at the end of their
tail
since gasopods are social creatures it's
even possible they use these clouds to
communicate with one another
but while the gasopods are the largest
creatures in the safe shallows they're
barely the tip of the proverbial iceberg
when it comes to planet 4546b
venturing into the vast kelp forest will
find a radically different environment
than the region we just left
here light is low thanks to the high
volume of creep vine plants creating a
hidden ecosystem just like kelp heavy
regions in earth's oceans
here and there clusters of creep vine
seeds cast shadows across the
environment like natural floodlights
i find myself wondering just what might
be hidden among the swaying fronds
that is a stalker the largest predator
that makes its home in the dense creep
vines
these fearsome customers possess a
series of dorsal ridges to help them
make tight turns and their long thin
snout is likely adapted for ensnaring
fish as it greatly resembles the
effective slender snouts of real-life
gariols
yet at the edge of the kelp forest one
stalker is behaving rather oddly
this stalker is picking up various
pieces of scrap metal with its snout
only to drop them after a short period
this behavior seems to serve no
practical purpose and indeed the
stalkers seem to simply have a fondness
for shiny objects puzzling as this
behavior might seem however the
barracuda a predatory earth fish is also
known to be attracted to shiny objects
because it's evolved to spot the silvery
glint of the fish it prefers to prey on
and when one considers the common prey
of the stalker this attraction to shiny
materials makes perfect sense
in the murky depths of the kelp forest
schools of fast-moving hoop fish light
up the dark with their vibrant coloring
a brief study of hoopfish anatomy
reveals they get their name from their
antennae which extends from the top and
bottom of their heads and bends around
their tails forming a hoop
exactly why these stunning fish possess
such intense and varied colors however
is a mystery
on the subject of mysteries the last
fish of the kelp forest we'll see is
quite the enigma meet the hoverfish a
peaceful herbivore that appears to hover
on pads at the end of its six legs using
these strange appendages the hoverfish
glides on the undersea currents and a
manner quite dissimilar to any other
fish on the planet it's surprising to
learn therefore that the hoverfish may
actually be a distant relative of the
non-descript bladder fish with their
legs actually a highly derived form of
the bladder fish's primitive vacuole
tubing
it's the kind of creature that could
only exist in the kelp forest
just beyond the waving creep vines the
landscape gives way to an alien grassy
plateau
here the sandy terrain is almost
completely carpeted with blood grass as
the sea floor is too dense for creep
vines to take hold and in the open space
even larger life forms are on the prowl
at the edge of the grassy plateau a
strange cloud of sand is gathering
as we swim closer to the unexpected
turbulence a creature with a huge fanged
mouth lashes out
this is a sand shark a predator with a
distinctive hunting strategy
the sand shark burrows into the sand
then erupts out when unsuspecting prey
swims by ending the chase with a snap
from its massive jaws
with segmented body armor and six rows
of fearsome teeth it's little wonder why
these predators are so effective
and alien as their behavior might seem
some sharks on earth employ a similar
strategy in swimming along the sandy
floor near the shoreline in search of
food although they of course don't
possess the extreme tunneling abilities
of the sand shark
a common target of the sand shark's
brutal ambushes swims overhead
the spade fish doesn't look like much
from most angles but glimpse one from
above and you'll spot its defining
feature a single cyclopsian eye
closer analysis of the spadefish
suggests it feeds on the sea floor and
its single eye allows the spadefish to
spot predators above it its mottled
green coloration suggests it normally
hides among seagrasses like many fish do
on earth
when a fish wanders onto the grassy
plateaus however it is hopelessly
exposed
on the far side of the grassy plateau
would appear to be tiny floating islands
hang miraculously in the water
upon closer inspection these chunks of
rock are all supported by colonies of
the same curious life form the floaters
transparent gelatinous blobs floaters
are at once oddly beautiful and slightly
silly looking analysis of these
creatures reveal there are actually
multiple microorganisms living in
symbiosis which we can compare to some
deep sea species of jellyfish the
floater's ability to suspend heavy
objects however remain something of a
mystery
swimming close by the floating islands
is a distant relative of the peeper
called the reginald the entire back end
of these oddly named fellows is composed
of one large fin and that finn's bright
coloration appears to be part of a
mating ritual
while it swims the reginald filters
algae and other plant-like material from
the water via four gill-like
forward-facing orifices
while this is a noteworthy adaptation
something looming behind the reginald
demands our attention
in the abyss beyond the edge of the
plateau the largest organism we've yet
to glimpse calls out through the deep
this is a reef back a leviathan class
organism that exceeds lengths of 220
feet or 70 meters and is thankfully
quite friendly
swimming closer to these gentle giants
we can see they're unlike any life form
we've yet to glimpse
possessing a thick exoskeleton their
shells have become an oasis of life
adult reef backs can support many
ecosystems on their back including many
types of coral and small fish
and nearby this adult is a baby a much
smaller creature whose shell is not yet
ready to support an ecosystem like its
parents
i confess i spent some time just
watching these creatures drift in their
pods and listening to them call out to
each other with complex sounds that
suggest a surprising amount of
intelligence
[Music]
with the sun now getting low it's time
to venture deeper into the abyss and
enter the foreboding final biome of the
dunes
in this vast empty expanse life often
flocks near hydrothermal vents
these great fissures on the sea floor
release a rich chemical soup into the
water much like those that support life
in the depths of earth's oceans
but it's not life among the vents that
concerns me
a terrifying roar comes from above
a reaper leviathan strikes out into the
abyss
this aggressive apex predator possesses
four mandibles at the front of its maw
to drag in large prey and at 180 feet or
55 meters in length a hungry reaper
leviathan can take down almost anything
analysis of the organism's biology
suggests the roar emitted by a reaper is
a form of sonar meaning if you can hear
it the reaper can see you
thankfully it seems this reaper isn't
hungry
and as i watch the deadly leviathan
vanish into the darkness i realize i've
done enough field work for the day
the sun has now set on 4546b
yet the wonders of this planet continue
as in the low light various regions of
the sea are transformed by stunning
displays of bioluminescence
even the reef back pod from earlier is
now giving off a striking glow
this eerie beauty suggests there are
many hidden wonders we have yet to
see to the north beyond the edge of the
grassy plateaus huge mushroom trees grow
in abundance
despite their name and appearance
mushroom trees are actually a
particularly long-lived species of coral
in the shade of these ancient giants a
new classification of life is swimming
these are jelly rays an ethereal ray
species with highly translucent bodies
in earth's oceans translucent life forms
are quite common in the lower light
depths the jelly rays are therefore a
sign we're getting closer to the deeper
and more fantastical regions of 4546b
beyond the safety of the mushroom forest
the twilight of the bulb zone awaits
here luminescent bulb bushes dominate
the landscape and have evolved to grow
in this rocky sandy environment thanks
to a highly advanced system of roots
and along the sea floor raging volcanic
geysers launch boiling liquid and chunks
of molten rock into the surrounding
water the extreme heat from these
geysers charboils any fish that swims
too
close an ominous light flickers in the
merck the source is an amp eo a huge
serpentine predator covered with glowing
prongs that produce zaps of electricity
these aggressive creatures use electric
discharges to intimidate other life
forms and kill their prey with a single
deadly shock
such living batteries might seem
biologically inexplicable but the
curious electric eel on earth might help
demonstrate how an organic creature
could produce an electric field
electric eels use disc shaped cells
packed into specialized organs to
generate their electric currents as
incredible as that might sound
so it's possible that the ampoules
prongs contain similar cells although
the bioelectricity of an ampoule is far
more extreme
a series of screeches announces the
approach of a legion of bone sharks
highly aggressive in territorial
carnivores it's unlucky to encounter so
many at once
their thickly armored exoskeletons which
give them their names are adapted not
just to deter larger predators but also
other bone sharks the distinctive
segmentation of these exoskeletons
suggests bone sharks might share a
common ancestor with the sand sharks we
glimpsed on our last outing if so it's a
fearsome family tree
while returning to the shallows to
prepare for the next leg of my journey i
spot a new type of colorful fish
something about the way it looks is
truly hypnotic and i want to swim closer
and then it bites my nose
that is a mesmer a sneaky little
creature that looks harmless while its
four fins are folded up but unfurled can
create hypnotic patterns that have
evolved to distract prey while it goes
in for the kill
thankfully it seems i'm a bit too big to
be swallowed up but this is one fish to
avoid
with supplies replenished it's time to
venture further into the unknown under
the sea floor networks of caves lead
deeper into the uncharted interior of
planet 4546b
some of these caves are massive and
contain entire ecosystems of their own
and the jelly shroom cave is one of the
most miraculous
here among the stalagmites grow jelly
shrooms massive highly luminescent flora
which might be distantly related to the
tiny acid mushrooms of the shallows
in the purple light of the jelly shrooms
shine the biters small carnivores that
stalk these caves for small prey
the antenna on their forehead seems to
resemble the deep sea angler fish's lure
at first glance but the biter's antenna
actually serves an entirely different
purpose
it contains olfactory organs that help
it detect bodily fluids in the water
in other words the biter can smell its
prey anywhere in the cavern
unless of course the biter becomes prey
itself
winding through the cave is an
unsettlingly lengthy crab snake the apex
predator of this environment what makes
this predator so deadly is not just its
size but its ability to hide in plain
sight the crab snake has a symbiotic
relationship with the local jelly
shrooms using their hollow interior as
the perfect layer from which to ambush
prey
in behavior and appearance the crab
snake somewhat resembles earth's bobbit
worm an unattractive predator that also
ambushes its prey
in the jellyshroom caves one needs to
keep an eye out
elsewhere on the seafloor another
shadowy cavern beckons
after many hours navigating the cave
system i surface in a cave that
strangely seems lit by daylight
i realize i've stumbled upon something
extremely rare for planet 4546b
dry land
this tiny island is the peak of an
undersea mountain connected to an
aquatic cave system and it's one of the
few places on the planet you can
encounter terrestrial life
scuttling along the beach are cave
crawlers as their name implies these
crab-like creatures have evolved to
crawl along the sides of cave walls
which is likely why they were able to
adapt to this fleeting land mass
relatively quickly
analysis of their biology suggests they
possess a gas exchange membrane to
breathe air instead of fully functional
terrestrial lungs
soaring overhead is a life form that has
spent much more time adapting to life
above the waves this is a sky ray an
avian creature that has remarkably
evolved powered flight although its
wings give it some resemblance to
aquatic ray species analysis shows no
particular genetic link instead the sky
ray appears to have split off from the
common evolutionary tree much earlier
than most other species on the planet
perhaps at a time when dry land was more
prevalent
in any case it seems we've now seen all
this island has to offer
[Music]
or maybe not on one end of the island is
a tremendous artificial spire this
mysterious monolith appears to be the
work of advanced extraterrestrials who
much like myself came to this planet
from afar
but did they come to study the life here
like i did or were their intentions more
sinister
in any case it seems this planet's
greatest secret is still waiting to be
uncovered
to the south the seafloor plunges lower
than ever before
we have come upon the grand reef here
orb-like blue plants called anchor pods
risk floating off due to their
gas-filled membrane only staying in
place due to their net like root system
and nearby stomp a herd of sea treader
leviathans
these vast herbivores roam the depths in
search of plants on which to graze
the thunderous nature of their rhythmic
steps is truly something to experience
[Music]
[Music]
perhaps the most curious thing about
these creatures is the fact they have
three legs something almost never
glimpsed in nature
analysis suggests their front leg is
actually an elongated snout used to
siphon plant material from the sea floor
and to maintain balance as alien as this
might seem there are some species of
earth tripod fish with elongated fins
they used to similarly stand on the sea
floor
right now it appears the sea treader
leviathans are migrating so it's best
not to disturb them
beneath the grand reef caverns take us
further into the abyss
here the intimidating crab squid waits
to butcher prey with its ten limbs
swim close to one and they'll unleash a
mysterious bioelectric discharge which
has the properties of an electromagnetic
pulse
while they appear to have massive brains
analysis suggests the large organ within
their translucent sac is actually their
stomach which the crab squid fill with
their bioluminescent prey
as a result they seem attracted to light
sources convincing me to make a hasty
exit from my submarine this turns out to
be a good call as it drags my sub into
the depths if there are other creatures
like the crab squid on the prowl down
here i'm going to need something a
little larger
for the next perilous leg of the journey
i'll be piloting a cyclops submarine a
vehicle that should be able to withstand
the crushing depths of the abyss
below the deep grand reef awaits a
surreal environment of eerie green fog
this is the lost river a region covered
in alkaline brine pools which give the
illusion of an underwater stream prime
pools also exist in earth's oceans and
are extremely toxic due to their high
salinity best not to get too close
above these pools drift the haunting
ghost rays
relatives of the jelly rays from the
mushroom forest in these extreme depths
the ghost rays have become almost
completely transparent to the point
where you can see the red of their
internal organs elsewhere in the lost
river blood crawlers the spindly
relatives of the cave crawlers stride
above the brine on stilt-like legs
rather unsettling forms of life
in the central chamber something truly
horrifying is waiting this ancient
fossil belongs to a colossus far larger
than any that currently swims through
the seas
indeed it's so massive that its rib cage
has become part of the lost river's
landscape
we should count ourselves lucky this
unknown genus seems to have gone extinct
long ago
yet still alive are the river prowlers
these aggressive transparent predators
haunt the gravesite of the leviathan
like vengeful ghosts
even more frightening their forehead
tendrils can lash out when attacking
allowing them to pull in prey
not the sort of creature you'd like to
encounter in the dark
but there is a strange beauty to certain
regions of the lost river in a cove
under the central chamber the brine
becomes a harmless blue and ghost rays
flock around a massive central tree this
tree appears to be an ancient nesting
round as it is grown around a giant
bioluminescent egg while the egg itself
is beautiful whatever hatches out of an
egg that size might not be
to find the adult form of the huge
creature that hatches from this egg we
must venture into the nightmarish
darkness of the dead zone
here at the edge of the habitable region
for most fauna we've found our giants or
they've found us
these aggressive monsters are ghost
leviathans and they're a major threat to
this expedition analysis of their jaws
suggest they feed on microscopic life
forms that help them reach their massive
sizes although they seem fully capable
of feeding on something larger time to
head back the way we came
the mystery of the giant egg has been
solved but that's not the only strange
thing in the lost river these ruins of a
massive alien structure resemble the one
on the island the structure is guarded
by these lifeforms the warpers who
possess a mind-bending ability at will
they can somehow fold space-time and
vanish into portals this is not the
ability of a natural life form it seems
we are dealing with an artificial
creation
searching for answers i enter the ruined
building
here we can see the unfinished
artificial body of a warper they did not
evolve and are a creation of the
extraterrestrials
but for what purpose translating a
digital message it seems these alien
architects came to 4546b
many years ago searching for a cure for
a disease and the warpers are their
artificial quarantine enforcers
given the lack of any living architects
on 4546b
it appears that they were unsuccessful
on a table in a nearby lab they've left
behind an egg of a curious creature
after returning to the surface to
recharge my submarine i hatch the egg
and this delightful life form emerges
this is a cuttlefish a friendly rotund
little creature that displays high
levels of intelligence and curiosity
i've also found it's quite a fan of
treats
analysis suggests it's possible this
creature has been imported from another
world or even genetically altered to be
extra friendly it's possible the
architect aliens kept them as pets just
like we do with dogs
it's tempting to stay longer with the
cuttlefish in the shallows yet i can't
help but feel that in the abyss there
are more mysteries i've yet to solve
beneath the lost river the landscape
blazes with the fiery glow of molten
rock we've reached the lava zone the
deepest environment of them all
here incredible heat resistant forms of
life have evolved like the crimson ray a
ray species that have developed a molten
coloring to help it blend in with the
lava and the magmarang a relative of the
boomerang with a beautiful glowing tail
fin
another remarkable form of life is the
lava larva a grub-like creature that
feeds off geothermal and electrical
energy i first learned this fact when i
found one stuck to the windshield of my
cyclops draining its energy while this
behavior is somewhat annoying the energy
conversion capabilities of this creature
are truly remarkable
on the molten floor is something highly
alarming these skeletons belong to
reaper leviathans it seems that
somewhere in the lava zone is a predator
so large it can drag reaper leviathans
into the depths
this doesn't bode well
basking in the red glow of the molten
rock are lava lizards these predators
are too small to be our culprits but
they're nonetheless quite deadly for
defense they are able to cover their
bodies with hardened lava-like natural
armor while such a behavior is far more
extreme than anything on earth scaly
foot snails which i've discussed on this
channel before can survive in volcanic
vents by incorporating iron scales into
their body like medieval armor however
lava lizard biology takes this to a new
level
at the end of the lava zone lurks a
massive chamber the loudest roar we've
encountered on our voyage shakes the
cavern
[Music]
we found our reaper leviathan slayer
this is a sea dragon leviathan
possessing both arms and tentacles these
creatures exceed 350 feet or 112 meters
in length sea dragons get their name
from their ability to consume molten
materials and expel them at their
adversaries like their breathing fire i
can only hope this absurdly deadly life
form doesn't notice me
no such luck
a huge blow from the leviathan rocks the
cyclops submarine as a result there
appears to be a minor leak
out of options i have to abandon ship
luckily i have one last hope in the
prawn suit a deep sea mechanical walker
that should make an ideal escape pod
ejecting from the cyclops it's a bit of
a drop to the bottom
but it appears my plan has worked as the
sea dragon leviathan thinks its foe has
been vanquished
here at the end of our journey lies a
final mysterious building with some
difficulty i pilot the prawn suit over
to it inside locked in a containment
facility the largest creature of
subnautica is waiting
this is a sea emperor leviathan and
although it appears to be a relative of
the sea dragon it is in no way hostile
like real world baleen whales the
largest creatures on earth its diet
consists solely of microorganisms
while the sea emperor leviathan is so
large i am unable to get a proper scan
of it it seems that it can somehow
manipulate neurons to communicate
telepathically as it told me of its
plight the sea emperor was entombed here
by the alien architects in the hope it
could provide a cure for their disease
which i believe is in strict violation
of the intergalactic code of biological
ethics
at the request of this intelligent
creature i agree to take its hatchlings
back to the surface with me
watching the first moments of baby sea
emperor's lives is a truly wondrous
experience even after all the biological
marvels i've glimpsed thus far
[Music]
sadly the sea emperor is at the end of
its lifespan and informs me that it
won't be coming with us
at the very least i'm happy i can help
their babies live on in freedom it is a
bittersweet conclusion to a long and
winding journey
with the sea emperor babies returning to
their natural habitat our study of this
region of subnautica is at its end
but there is another region of planet
4546b
sector 0 is a region of extremely low
temperatures where organisms of all
types have had to adapt to the cold
beginning on the ice floats above the
shallows a curious lifeform makes its
home in this region where land meets the
sea huddled together on a float is a
flock of waddling penguins penguins are
small predatory fauna which aren't the
most graceful on land when a penguin
dives underwater however the creature's
unique retractable tail allows them to
twist through the currents with
remarkable grace
despite their cute appearance penguins
are carnivores and their beaks open
horizontally revealing a rather alarming
set of teeth
in their body shape and general behavior
penguins show a high degree of
convergence with earth penguins with
both species adapting to an arctic
environment in similar ways
and on any ice float with penguins you
will also find panglings the juvenile
form of penguins who never stray far
from their parents even more than adults
infant panglings are extremely awkward
on land but what they might lack in
overall balance they make up for in
endless enthusiasm and while penguins
might possess the same somewhat alarming
fanged mouth they're remarkably docile
creatures perfectly content with being
gently lifted up
as nice as it is to briefly hold a baby
pangling however i don't want to disrupt
their natural routines
as we dive into the polar waters a
shallow surprisingly warm region awaits
just under the ice floats the landscape
of this coastal sea is dominated by
coral bridges great arches formed by
rapidly growing polyps that can exceed
600 feet or 200 meters in length
bioluminescent blue barnacles grow on
the coral's underside which ascan
suggests are actually separate species
taking advantage of the bridge's
structure but why would the coral
bridges grow into such strange arcing
shapes the answer lies in a phenomenon
known as thigmotropism a pattern of
growth observed in earth plants in
response to touch stimulus thigmatropism
is what allows vines to wrap around and
climb up holes and it's the likely
reason the great coral bridges always
grow from one rock to another
just beyond these coral bridges we
encounter an arctic peeper who watches
for predators with its massive yellow
eyes
relatives of the common peeper in the
tropical seas arctic peeper's scales
have evolved a white hue for better
camouflage against the ice other
familiar herbivores also swim here like
the translucent bladder fish and the
vibrant hoop fish together these species
form an important base in the sector
zero food chain for the larger less
familiar creatures that lurk under the
ice
swimming northwards i've reached a
region known as the sparse arctic this
entire biome is situated under thick ice
shelves and receives a little direct
sunlight on the underside of these
icebergs hazardous ice formations known
as brinicles protrude like jagged fangs
highly unstable brinicles frequently
shatter and crash to the ocean floor yet
as foreboding as the sparse arctic seems
some truly remarkable species thrive
here
this odd looking fellow is called a
brine wing with its rotund form and
beak-like mouth it gives the impression
of an ineffectual herbivore but the
brine wing is a powerful predator to
hunt it unleashes a rapid-fire torrent
of supercooled saline solution that
freezes in the water and can encase its
prey in ice
a scan suggests that the brine wing uses
a highly specialized bladder to produce
this super cool brine from the
surrounding salt water as unusual in
adaptation as this might seem the earth
archer fish can shoot down insects using
water jets launched from their
specialized mouths and are remarkably
accurate
other species in the sparse arctic have
very different survival strategies like
the enormous titan hole fish a
slow-moving herbivore with a strange
hole in the center of its body the titan
whole fish is a relative of the tiny
guppy-sized tropical whole fish and is
so much larger than its cousin you can
actually swim through the hole at its
center
but what is the purpose of this hole a
scan suggests the gel-like interior is
lined with hundreds of eggs but
curiously the egg's dna doesn't match
that of the whole fish
the mystery of the eggs is revealed when
i spot a tiny life form swimming
alongside the whole fish
soon many others join in swarming like a
bee colony around a hive these are
symbiotes small predators that have
evolved to make their nests in the whole
of the titan whole fish and in turn
defend the whole fish at all cost and
even provide it with food this highly
cooperative lifestyle is an example of a
mutualistic partnership one of the few
on planet 4546b
as a result the titan holefish has
evolved to be remarkably unintelligent
swimming forward on impulse fully
trusting the complex ecosystem that
supports its every need
just beyond the sparse arctic the bare
sand gives way to the teeming arctic
kelp forest
here creep vine plants sway in the polar
current casting light into the depths
with their bioluminescent seeds
these creep vine plants are close
relatives of the green variety which
grow in the warm waters of the tropics
although the chemical composition of the
polar waters has turned them a pale
yellow among the fronds familiar fish
like the boomerang flip between the
leaves and some very unfamiliar fish
swim here also these extremely bizarre
life forms are called spinner fish and
have perhaps the most peculiar method of
swimming ever conceived
using three pairs of siphons along the
side of their body spinner fish jet
along like living water wheels at a
glance its bizarre body plan somewhat
resembles the larval form of an ocean
sunfish but ultimately the spinner fish
is one of a kind
speaking of one of a kind i soon spot an
incredible life form i'm just about to
scan it when it swims in and snatches
the scanner right from my hands
frustrated i give chase and find the
creature occasionally looks back and
waves the stolen scanner to mock me
thankfully i'm able to out maneuver it
and snatch my tool back
finishing the scan i discover this
creature might be annoying but it's
truly remarkable with both a developed
brain and finger like appendages for
object manipulation it's called a sea
monkey a nickname it shares with earth
brine shrimp unlike those sea monkeys
however the sea monkey of planet 4546b
seems about as intelligent as an actual
primate meaning it's the smartest
life-form i've found in sector zero
given time the sea monkeys might have an
incredible future trajectory i just hope
they evolve to be less annoying
with the kelp forest thoroughly charted
it's time to regroup on the surface
sticking my head above the water however
i find the shallows are engulfed in a
dangerous polar storm looking around i
realize the penguin flock from earlier
might be in serious danger
upon arriving at their ice float however
i find the penguins unbothered by the
weather simply huddling for warmth and
waiting out the rain
truly penguins are intriguing creatures
with the sun thankfully returning it
occurs to me that there's still much i
have to learn about penguin flock
dynamics but i don't want to disrupt
them further with my presence
time for some innovation
i've devised an alternative less
conspicuous method of observation this
machine is my spy penguin and it will
hopefully be able to keep an eye on the
penguin flock with its hidden cameras
while i continue my expedition across
sector zero i'm uncertain if the
penguins will be fooled into accepting
this robot as one of their own but the
only way to find out is to test it as
inconspicuously as i can i deploy the
robot
taking control via an auxiliary remote i
navigate the spy pangling into the midst
of the flock it's not a perfect disguise
but the penguins don't seem particularly
bothered by its presence either though
it's unlikely this robot is fooling them
it doesn't appear to disrupt their
natural behavior i'll leave the flock
under its watchful eye and head deeper
into the unknown regions
even further out to sea the mysterious
lillypad islands hang in the water
seemingly by miraculous means
these floating chunks of rock are held
up by giant lily pads an enormous type
of plant that defines this ecosystem
giant lily pads are indeed so large that
it's possible to stand on their leafy
tops without fear of sinking but it's
the bizarre life that swims in the lily
pad shadows that makes this region truly
unique
take for example the hilariously named
newt fish with its colorful markings and
innocent beak-like snout the newt fish
can easily pass as a herbivore but any
fish that makes that mistake is soon
swallowed whole
the newt fish's beak is in fact a
stretchy extendable lip lined with
barb-like teeth it uses to envelop prey
this kind of extendable mouth somewhat
resembles that of the sarcastic
fringehead of the pacific ocean
best to keep an eye out
but there are bigger predators here than
the newt fish the brute shark is an
aggressive predator that scours the
depths with its ghostly white eyes
with huge fangs and a massive bony jaw
they feed on just about anything they
can catch
like many earth sharks they prefer to
attack via ambush from above or below
the only good news is that while they're
deadly brute sharks aren't particularly
fast still if i don't keep my distance i
might be on the menu
closer to the surface i spot a
remarkably colorful life form swimming
nearer the edges of my vision blur and i
feel just a little dizzy
the sky always been that color
everything feels
floaty
for a while
eventually the effect wears off and with
a clear head i understand what just
happened that life form known as a lily
paddler possesses the unique ability to
disorient would-be attackers with the
mesmerizing patterns on its colorful
appendages
it's an impressive defense and a vital
one for a creature like a lily paddler
which is otherwise quite vulnerable i
just wish it didn't make my head hurt
a shadow passes overhead
just above me a whale-sized leviathan
opens its mouth to a tremendous size and
swallows an entire school of fish in
just a single gulp
this is a glow whale and while they're
highly effective at feeding on small
fish they're thankfully quite gentle
at almost 100 feet or 30 meters in
length they're the first leviathan class
organism i've encountered in sector zero
and a highly intelligent one
a scan of the glow whales indicate they
possess many organs that are capable of
bioluminescence
most notably around the corners of their
eyes and the ends of their horns
careful not to startle it i brush a glow
whale under its eye causing a faint glow
it's difficult to interpret whether this
is a random response or an attempt to
send a message
in any case the glow whale seems content
with my presence as i watch it rejoin
its pod i wish i could stay with this
spectacular life form for longer
but before the sun sets there's one last
region i need to chart
underneath layers of snow and ice there
are telltale signs that a permanent
landmass makes up a portion of sector
zero dry land is so scarce on this ocean
planet that it's impossible to guess
what sorts of life forms might live
farther inland
passing through a nero canyon i find
strange plant animal hybrids that seem
to be growing from the walls
these are thermal lilies organisms that
spend most of their time tracking the
sun and absorbing its energy but also
turn to track by movement as i pass a
scan suggests they aren't dangerous and
thanks to the thermal radiation they've
absorbed they're actually a welcome
source of heat in sector zero's frigid
interior
still it's unsettling the way they
follow me
beyond the canyon a snowy landscape far
too vast to traverse on foot awaits
luckily i have an alternate method of
transportation this is a snow fox a
hoverbike designed for land-based
expeditions zooming over the arctic
terrain i find it's got a bit of a kick
at these speeds i should be able to
chart this region fairly effectively
a short time later i spot a hairy
creature in the distance the question is
is it friendly
not friendly putting the snow fox in
reverse i discover the creature gives
chase with alarming speed after several
near misses i back away to a safe
distance
that quadrupedal predator was a snow
stalker and while it nearly sank its
claws into me i can't help but be
excited at the discovery of a
terrestrial land animal on planet 4546
with its white fur and imposing bulk the
snow stalker has converged on a body
plan similar to earth polar bears
i'm curious about the lineage of this
land animal a brief analysis reveals
surprisingly that the snow stalker is
actually a distant relative of the fully
aquatic stalker i encountered in the
tropical region while these two species
diverged a long time ago there are still
some telltale signs of their relation in
the shape of their head and their dorsal
spines
a fascinating genetic ancestry
speaking of which a short way off from
the snow stalker i spot what appears to
be its cub playing in the snow
just a fraction of the size of its
parent this baby snow stalker is far
less aggressive than an adult
well
mostly
trekking onward i reach an ice sheet
marked by jagged towering ice formations
this region is known as the arctic
spires and it's home to a giant a huge
head bursts from below the ice
seconds later a massive serpentine
leviathan rises into the air and nearly
takes me out with a swipe from its
massive horn this terror of the frozen
planes is an ice worm at over 300 feet
or 90 meters long it's almost twice the
size of a reaper leviathan and by far
the largest creature i've seen in sector
zero
its glowing horn is superheated through
an exothermic chemical reaction allowing
it to melt through the very ice its prey
is standing on time to make a fast exit
speeding away on my snow fox i spot the
snow stalker and its cub from earlier
fleeing beside me
we barely make it to safety with
creatures like the ice worm around i
think i might put off doing more field
work till tomorrow
while the sun sets overhead i check in
to find my spy pangling has become a
veritable member of the flock and has
done an excellent job keeping an eye on
its feathered companions
together my penguin bot and i sit and
watch the gorgeous sector zero sunset
and with the night comes a final
surprise
the sky is lit up by a dazzling aurora
similar to the aurora borealis in the
northern latitudes of earth on our
planet these northern lights are a
result of disturbances in the
magnetosphere caused by solar wind and
we can theorize that they have the same
origin on planet 4546b
it's a beautiful imposing display that
can make one feel a little isolated in
the universe but with my spy pangling
beside me i don't feel truly alone
a transmission interrupts my thoughts it
seems i'm picking up a mysterious
communication
but from where
and who or what is sending it out
the mysterious transmission is emanating
from the murky waters of a region known
as the deep twisty bridges
diving into these alien depths the only
light comes from the bioluminescent
coral bridges that spiral throughout
this cavernous abyss
the dimness of the deep has transformed
all life that swims in the gloom
like pale ghosts the skeletal spine fish
haunt these depths a subspecies of the
hoop fish the spine fish have become
nearly translucent and possess rib-like
markings that give them a deathly
appearance the phenomenon of certain
deep-sea fish becoming transparent is
present in earth's oceans as well
notably in the barrel eye fish an animal
that possesses a head made of
translucent tissue to allow it to look
upwards and spot its preferred prey
right through the top of its head
truthfully the barrel eye fish is an
animal that would seem right at home in
the oceans of planet 4546p
but the spinefish isn't a carnivore so
despite its haunting appearance it's no
real danger
but there are genuine dangers here a
huge predator swims torpedo-like among
the bridges
with unexpected speed it rushes in and
attempts to swallow me whole a fate i'm
barely able to avoid by prying its jaws
open
the predator continues to give chase but
i escape by swimming into a crevice it
can't reach
that terror of the abyss was a squid
shark a highly aggressive fauna species
that is the apex predator of this region
analysis suggests its terrifying bursts
of speed come from two vents on either
side of its body which provide jet
propulsion through this adaptation the
squid shark like its name suggests
combines the most formidable aspects of
deep sea squids and macro predator shark
species
the result is a deadly amalgamation i'll
have to keep a wide distance from if i
ever want to find the source of the
transmission
staying close to the ocean floor a
curious waving plant catches my eye
swimming in for a closer look the life
form lashes out with a long tendril and
pulls me towards a mouth-like opening
after a few frantic punches the creature
releases his tentacle and i swim out of
range
that was a spiky trap which isn't
actually a plant at all but a highly
unusual form of animal this carnivorous
life form blends into the terrain
camouflaging itself among vegetation and
catching fish and unwary explorers with
its adhesive tendrils when they swim too
close
and despite its lack of mobility this
strategy seems to be highly effective
in the deep twisty bridges one must
always stay alert
elsewhere on the seafloor i discover a
strange glowing device near the signal
source this ruined fragment matches the
strange structures present in the
tropics which belonged to a group of
alien architects i'd assumed all the
architects had perished but with the
signal beckoning me onwards i wonder if
i was mistaken
at last i reach a mysterious undersea
facility as i navigate through the halls
an unknown voice urges me to hurry
entering a central chamber i find both
the signal and the voice have been
coming from this cube-shaped computer
the voice turns out to be that of an
architect who thousands of years before
had stored his consciousness within the
computer speaking through the cube the
architect explains he was a scientist
like me and is now likely the last of
his kind wanting to help a fellow
researcher i offer to transfer the
lonely consciousness to my field
computer and take him with me on my
expedition the architect accepts and
warns me to brace for transfer
a little too late i realized something
might have been lost in translation
awakening with a mild headache i can
hear the architect's voice quite clearly
and learn this is because he downloaded
himself directly into my brain it was an
honest mistake as architects don't
recognize a boundary between technology
and the body while this is an intriguing
revelation about architect biology it
means i now have an unanticipated mental
roommate
returning to the shallows we formulate a
plan
we'll use our combined knowledge to
continue to chart the biology of life in
sector zero but along the way we'll
gather the material needed to fabricate
a body that my new friend can transfer
into
he tells me his designation is
a-l-a-n
so i'll call him alan
picking up where alan's research left
off we venture to the sprawling expanse
of the west arctic
here great icebergs float above a
seemingly bottomless region of the sea
creating a profound sense of scale
and among these giant icebergs swim
undiscovered oddities
gliding through the blue is an animal
that is difficult to unravel with two
sets of wing-like fins it's not clear
what sort of life form we're observing
at a glance
but this life form is in fact an arctic
ray the first of many race species in
sector zero while its body plan has
clearly diverged from earth rays by
having four wing structures instead of
two the arctic ray is a highly agile
life form
and it has to be if it wants to avoid
the top predator of the west arctic this
is a pinakarid an intelligent and social
predator that spends half its time on
ice floats above the water pinocarids
have converged on an ecological niche
similar in many respects to earth seals
and are remarkably friendly towards
humans even showing acute curiosity when
lured in with a tasty piece of fish
allen's analysis suggests their 14
flippers make them acrobatic hunters
underwater
this unusually high number of flippers
resembles the anatomy of anomalocarids a
group from earth's cambrian period who
similarly possessed multiple fins for
locomotion
descending deeper into the west arctic
waters what appears to be a legion of
pulsating eyes stare back at us this is
in fact a colony of eye jellies
gelatinous life forms that harbor an
enormous hemispheric eye on the tops of
their bodies
despite their somewhat alarming
appearance these creatures live
remarkably passive lives drifting slowly
on the currents in vast colonies paying
little mind to other species alan notes
that they are capable of releasing a
small electric shock if we swim too
close however so we'll give the group a
wide berth
upon one of the west arctic icebergs we
notice an entrance to a small cave
venturing inside the reflected ice
caught in the afternoon sun resembles
the brilliance of the night sky
and within this ethereal cave a strange
egg appears stranded on a cave wall
it's not a species alan recognizes and
it seems about ready to hatch
bringing the egg to the warmth of the
shallows after some time this creature
emerges the unusual hatchling turns out
to be a tri-valve and much like the
cuttlefish of the tropics it's a
remarkably friendly and intelligent
creature that is quite a fan of treats a
scan suggests the body of this naturally
inquisitive life form is made of a
flexible exoskeleton and somewhat
resembles the shell of an earth nautilus
in its shape it's tempting to relax in
the shallows with the tri valve for
longer but alan reminds me we still have
other areas to chart
and the next leg of the journey will be
perilous indeed luckily i have a new
classification of submersible to aid in
the voyage
this is a sea truck an underwater
vehicle that will allow us to go lower
into the crushing depths of sector zero
than ever before
at the helm of the sea truck we venture
into the vast biome of the thermal zone
the edge of this region an area known as
the thermal spires is marked by a forest
of hydrothermal vents
these chimney-shaped structures are
formed from dissolved minerals pushed up
from the planet's crust and are home to
all kinds of remarkable life
gliding between the vents is a brightly
colored feather fish
defined by their unusual crescent-shaped
fin structure feather fish are one of
the more graceful herbivores in sector
zero a highly successful species in some
regions they gather in schools numbering
in the thousands
we are admiring one such school when an
intimidating creature paddles by this
vicious looking armored predator is a
crypto sukis and is covered in sharp
spines snapping wildly it closes in
and then retreats just as quickly
as it turns out the contrarian
cryptosucus is one species where its
bark is truly worse than its bite while
it appears fearsome a scan suggests its
menacing shell is adapted to aid in heat
absorption among the thermal vents and
so this false tyrant paddles away to try
and scare off something a bit smaller
far deeper into the thermal zone the
dark blue of a biome known as the tree
spires beckons these waters are lit by
the bioluminescent flora that grow on
the sides of tree-like hydrothermal
vents
in this distinctive region the equally
distinctive discus fish undulates along
its flat semi-transparent body is highly
unusual and it seems to contain strange
green organs a study of the discus fish
reveals this green color comes from
symbiotic algae-like organisms living
within specialized body cavities that
provide the discus fish with food
strange as this might sound emerald sea
slugs of earth also photosynthesize
using algae that grows within their
bodies since there isn't much sunlight
here in the depths for plant growth it's
likely the discus fish spends part of
its life cycle in a brighter region of
sector zero
elsewhere in the thermal zone we can
spot a teardrop shaped arrow ray this
ray species has an elongated body and a
rather triangular head which it can tilt
to perform unpredictable maneuvers at
the ends of the arrowrays fins grow
sharp talon-like tips that deter
attackers who manage to catch up meaning
the aero ray certainly isn't defenseless
a huge life form passes in front of our
submarine without warning it shrieks and
latches onto the windshield with its
front mandibles gunning the engine i'm
barely able to twist out of the deadly
grip that leviathan class organism was a
chelycerate a brute that grows over 130
feet or 30 meters in length its body is
covered in a thick segmented exoskeleton
that grows in overlapping plates which
may offer protection from the
atmospheric pressure since the
chelycerate are so aggressive and
potentially deadly they're a challenging
species to study up close
fascinating as they are we both hope we
don't encounter any more of them
at the very bottom of the sea floor an
indescribably massive life form is
waiting this is a vent garden a
stationary leviathan that anchors itself
above hydrothermal vents and consumes
100 of the nutrients they release at
over
360 feet or 110 meters the vent garden
is by far the largest leviathan of
sector zero the only things in earth's
oceans that resemble vent gardens are
certain types of siphonophores
soft-bodied entities which like the vent
gardens are also technically colonies of
smaller organisms working in tandem but
what's most incredible about the vent
garden is the internal ecosystem of
plants it supports within its hollow
bell-shaped center and remarkably a scan
indicates it would be safe to enter this
environment ourselves
exiting the submarine we tentatively
swim up towards the light
and at last emerge within the microcosm
of the vent garden
this mini ecosystem supports aquatic
flora on branching platforms that in
turn help absorb some of the heavy
metals emitted by the vents below
exploring the hidden biosphere of event
garden is a downright magical experience
but the unknown still beckons
pushing further into the abyss than ever
before we've reached the edge of the
habitable region for most fauna
surrounded by total darkness alan is
starting to get worried that we've
strayed too far
and he seems to be right a huge
chalicerate emerges from the blackness
almost twice the size as the one from
the tree spires this pale mutation is
called a void chilicerate and it's not
alone we've stumbled into a pack
time to head back as fast as we possibly
can
i don't think either of us plan on
revisiting this area anytime soon
returning to the safety of the research
base i have with alan's help given our
station a bit of an upgrade as it turns
out having an alien scientist downloaded
into your brain can be quite useful and
while alan still doesn't understand the
purpose of basic things like music or
why i start every morning with coffee
together we've successfully mapped much
of sector zero yet a deep scan tells us
there's a strange signature coming from
a large ice cave we've yet to visit
the cave is far to the inland of sector
zero
at last we enter the cavern and discover
an enormous frozen creature encased in a
cave wall this leviathan-class organism
has been entombed here for thousands of
years as alan remembers encountering
their kind when he was a researcher here
long ago
since this species is hopefully now
extinct the only way to study it is to
drill into the ice
taking a dna sample from the creature's
foot i'm able to determine the life form
was quadrupedal and spent at least a
portion of its time on land something
unusual for planet 4546b
perhaps this frozen leviathan suggests
an era in the distant past where land
was more plentiful and great titans like
this one roamed across it in any case
i'm certainly glad this particular
specimen is now long dead i think
at long last we now have all the
necessary materials needed to fabricate
alan's new body the only problem is that
the one architect facility that can
create such a compatible vessel is
located in a region known as the crystal
caves these caverns are the deepest
biome of them all and the last frontier
of planet 4546b
and since the refractive crystals mean
any scans of the region come back
fragmented there's no telling what else
is down there
navigating the purple chasm this
environment possesses a strange beauty
and equally strange life forms can be
found in these depths
the triops is a tiny organism that
spends much of its time hiding from
predators in the surrounding terrain the
triops stand out biologically however
thanks to their distinctive three-eyed
ocular system in nature a life-form
evolving three distinct eyes isn't
particularly common but it's not
altogether unheard of artemia is a genus
of aquatic crustaceans that possess two
eyes mounted on flexible stalks and a
third stationary eye situated in the
center of their head
so the diminutive triops is in good
company
further into the planet's crust we've
arrived at the fabricator caves a
secondary layer of the crystal caves
where a high concentration of the
element beryllium led to the formation
of striking red crystals to brave this
extreme geochemical environment i've
donned the prawn suit a deep sea
mechanical walker that kept me safe on
the last stages of my journey in the
tropics
stomping along the ocean floor i spot a
small crustacean nearby
given its diminutive stature i'm not
particularly worried until it launches
itself at my prawn suit this is a rock
puncher a pint-sized predator which is a
heavy hitter nonetheless its hardened
claws can thrust forward at close to the
speed of sound to break rock and bone
alike in many respects the rock puncher
is similar to the precocious mantis
shrimp these creatures possess
spring-loaded biological hammer clubs
that can strike prey faster than the
speed of a bullet giving the mantis
shrimp the ability to truly punch above
its weight class and the rock puncher is
no different time to de-escalate the
situation by moving elsewhere
we're now very close to the fabrication
facility when a thunderous roar shakes
the cavern
a huge leviathan grips my prawn suit and
pulls me towards a glowing gullet after
smacking it with my prawn suit's arms
the nightmare serpent temporarily drops
me
backing into a narrow gap it seems the
leviathan cannot follow we're safe
for now
that was a shadow leviathan which at
almost 200 feet or 60 meters is the
single most dangerous predator of sector
zero its elongated body gives this
monster the appearance of a giant eel
analysis suggests its bioluminescent
digestive tract glows due to
light-seeking phytoplankton that draw in
on wary fish and its mouth also secretes
a highly acidic compound
we're lucky we were able to escape such
a terrifying life-form form unscathed
or have we
looking up i notice my prawn suit is
leaking from its fight with the shadow
leviathan
our only hope now is to reach the
fabrication facility before the shadow
finds me again
but with the familiar green glow of
architect technology up ahead at last
we've reached the ultimate destination
heading inside i find a facility quite
like the one i first discovered alan
within putting in the materials we've
gathered the facility begins the process
of fabrication
activating the final sequence alan and i
watch as the vessel is constructed
this new body is composed of the dna of
27 different species and various
inorganic materials as well so it should
be quite the upgrade at last alan's body
is complete after so much effort it's
almost surreal to reach this point i
think about telling my friend he looks a
bit like a glowing purple centaur but
decide that would probably just confuse
him with alan now out of my mind and
settled into his new vessel he doesn't
need my assistance to continue his
research
we both return to the surface and alan
informs me he'll be going back to his
home planet via warp gate to see if
there are any other architects still
living it is a somewhat bittersweet
feeling as i realize this is goodbye
working with another researcher in
particular an alien one has been a
special privilege
alone on planet 4546b once more i
consider all i've seen on this wondrous
planet from nerve-wracking dangers to
unexpected allies it's been a remarkable
journey but now at last the time has
come for me to depart as well
for who knows what else is waiting among
the stars
and as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious see you in
the next video
you